- [Kelly Clarkson] Have
a seat! You look so cute!
- You do!
Thank you.
- [Kelly] Shoes tie into
the like, festive...
- Thank you.
- So cute.
So are, Merry Christmas.
- This so great, thank you.
- I love this time of year,
'cause our set always looks awesome.
And it makes me happy.
- [Linda] It's so wonderful.
It's a wonderland.
- [Kelly] They do, I know.
It does make you happy, twinkly lights.
I'm just saying.
- [Linda] Yeah.
- [Kelly] You could live
anywhere, anywhere in the world,
you put twinkly lights,
and all of a sudden it's like, fabulous.
- [Linda] Yes.
- [Kelly] Um, are you doing
anything big next week?
- We are big, you know, family people.
So we go, and find our
family wherever they are.
Sometimes we have to go
up to Northern California,
but this is year we get to...
- [Kelly] Oh that's beautiful.
- Yes, it's beautiful.
Cold, but beautiful, compared
to southern California.
But not compared to...
- [Kelly] I'm gonna be in
Montana, so it's real cold.
- [Linda] Yeah? - Yeah.
- [Linda] I'm being a baby.
- Yeah.
- [Linda] Um, but you
know, so we'll go, I think,
to my sister's which is really fun.
She's got goats, and chickens, and...
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- Yeah, and she hosts everybody.
And it's super, she's the best.
It's super fun.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
Is it like a little farm?
- It's kind of, not, not
totally, but you know.
- Yeah.
- As close as I get.
- [Kelly] I love that. - Yeah.
- [Kelly] Goats and
chickens, that's awesome.
So what was the toy,
whenever you were a kid,...
Whenever I was a kid I loved Care Bears.
- I loved Cabbage Patch Kids.
- [Kelly] Oh, Cabbage Patch...
- That was like big one, the big one.
And my parents were so sweet.
My mom and my best friend's mom,
they stood outside all night
in front of a Toys "R" Us,
I think, and then waited
to get a Cabbage Patch.
But you could just only
get whatever they gave you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And when they, when they
got there in line, you know,
I wanted a little girl Cabbage
Patch kid, and it was a boy.
So my best friend and I,
we got boy Cabbage Patch Kids dolls.
We were the only like girls
in class with boy dolls.
Which then we tried to
turn into like something,
you know, it was obviously disappointing.
- special, but yeah.
- Yeah, but then there was a...
But, you know he only
got to wear like shorts,
and a t-shirt, I think. Like
all the other dolls had...
- [Kelly] I remember him.
- lots of accessories, yeah.
So, I had this doll named Herbie,
but then my parents went,
and there was this thing in San
Francisco which was so cool,
where they took the kids,
and you could wait in line.
And there was a "doctor" in there at,
and there was a Cabbage Patch inside.
And it was in this old
Victorian, in San Francisco.
And you went inside,
and you got to adopt a Cabbage Patch kid.
Yeah.
- Wow.
- So, I think my parents were like, uh-oh,
we better go...
- [Kelly] go big.
- Yeah, yeah we better go big now.
- [Kelly] A boy Cabbage Patch doll.
- But I mean there's
nothing wrong with a boy
Cabbage Patch, it's great, but...
- [Kelly] No, but when
you're little kid expecting
a girl one...
- [Linda] Yeah.
- That could be a disappoint...
- [Linda] I mean, I very much
love my son. But, but yeah.
So I went, and I adopted
the Cabbage Patch kid.
And it was really like a whole
event that they did for kids.
And the doctor put the...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- stethoscope into the Cabbage Patch,
and the little heads were popping out.
And then he made it...
He must have been doing this,...
- Yeah, to make the sound.
- because I thought I heard the heartbeat.
So we, you know,...
- [Kelly] It was like magical though.
- Yes, it was completely magical.
- [Kelly] I love when people
do like random stuff like that
you find, and then...
- [Linda] Yeah.
- it makes...
It's the smallest thing that
makes your kid just like, glow.
- [Linda] Yes, it is.
And that's sort of like the
spirit of the whole season is
like to do something magical,
some kind of surprise.
- [Kelly] Yeah. - I love that.
- [Kelly] And also suppress expectations.
(Kelly laughing)
- Well, yes, yes, yes.
Dude, dude, that's the
spirit of our household.
So did you, did you
act in Christmas plays,
like growing up?
- [Linda] I did.
I mean I...
It was definitely you
had to kind of be in it,
'cause I went to a school
where like there was always
a Christmas play.
And then that was...
- [Kelly] Me too.
- Yeah, and so um, so yes.
I was like, I think, you
know, we were angels.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Linda] And you know,
you are, you know the...
(distant audience gawking)
- [Kelly] Remember...
- [Linda] Oh, yeah!
That's my best friend.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, you're adorable.
(Linda laughing)
- Thanks.
- So you've always been a
bangs kid. I like it, yeah.
- [Linda] I, you know, I
wasn't for a long time,
and I feel like this whole
past few years I got back to
my bangs.
- [Kelly] I always think it's
a good idea until it isn't
after I do it.
And then it's like, I just...
- [Linda] Well, they're
very hard to grow out.
- I, well, and you, exactly...
And do you feel they
poke you in your eyes?
- [Linda] Well, I kind like it.
I feel like it's a little bit
of a shield from the world,
so...
- [Kelly] We're different.
That might be my...
- [Kelly] I'm like, "Hello, world!"
Like, I'm like, I don't wanna shield.
That's amazing.
What was the first time you were on stage?
I, I think mine were like
Christmas plays at like church,
or something.
- [Linda] I was...
We did Noah's Ark.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- And so we were in pairs
with my same friend,
my best friend Shannon.
And we were skunks.
(distant Kelly amused laughing)
Yeah.
- [Kelly] You were a stinky animal.
- [Linda] And, and you can
clearly see that someone's
calling me stinky in that picture.
- You're excited about it.
- Yeah, they called us
"Stinky" for like years.
But you know, clearly a very cute costume.
But when you're a kid you're
like, "Why am I the skunk?"
- [Kelly] Yeah, you wanna be like...
- So and so's a butterfly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You've got the...
That's awesome.
This is setting up so much
future therapy though.
It's awesome.
It's like all those...
- [Linda] No, it, it...
You know, it's good.
All those things they teach
you to be sort of resilient,
and roll along
- [Kelly] It builds character.
- with like...
- [Kelly] I agree.
- We always kinda laughed
about it in my family.
- [Kelly] I, I literally, I
don't, I think I was the lion,
and I accidentally ended
up putting it on backwards.
And my tail was...
(distant audience laughing)
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh,
I knocked over the waves.
- Builds character.
- [Linda] Yes.
- Oh, you knocked over the stage?
- [Linda] Yes, and I was like the...
Because they had the like the
old timey like move the waves
back and forth.
And I came down the stairs,
and I flopped over all the waves.
And I...
- You wanted to make an entrance.
- I'll never be an actor,...
(distant Kelly laughing)
you know?
- [Kelly] From that moment.
- At five, I was like,
"Oh, there goes my shot."
- [Kelly] Isn't it so
funny when you're a kid,
even when you're like a teen,
everything is so devastating.
- [Linda] Oh it's so big.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, so big!
- [Kelly] We were silly.
(distant audience applauding)
So the final season her show, Dead to Me,
is on Netflix now.
So congrats on everything with Dead to Me.
I love the show so much.
So are you happy with how it ended?
- [Linda] We were, you know,
it's bittersweet of course,
because it's our last season.
But we were so happy to
know it was our last season,
'cause at least we get to wrap it up well.
You know?
So we get to wrap it up the
way that it was envisioned
to be wrapped up by our
creator, you know, Liz Feldman.
And, and Christina and I
were just so happy, you know,
just to be able to to be
there, and to do it together.
- [Kelly] Absolutely. - Yeah.
- I just love that
there's serious subjects,
but there's so much kind
of dark humor, and...
- [Linda] Yeah. - It's just...
- [Linda] Yeah.
- It's so...
- It's got a little of everything.
- [Kelly] It's so good.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, I love, I'm a fan..
- And the series showed
the power of friendship
during grief.
So has that been true
in your life as well?
- [Linda] Absolutely, oh my God.
And I don't know how, you know,
I, I think the hardest thing
to think about is people
when they feel lonely, and
going through something,
something big.
Because there's really, like for me,
my friends have really
gotten me through things.
And my family, you know,
we're all very close.
But... - [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, I'm so, so lucky to
have so many amazing friends
in my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it really has carried you through,
'cause no matter how hard you
try, stuff happens, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, you can't control...
- And you feel sad, or
lonely, or you know,
things are shocking in your
life, or traumatic, and...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's just nice to have a support system.
- [Kelly] Well, speaking
of support system,
we actually just had
Christina Applegate on...
- I watched you guys, that
was such a great interview.
- [Kelly] I love her.
And I wanted to bring that up,
like if you had that
support system in your life,
because she explained
that you were part of
the support system in hers
whenever she was diagnosed
with MS.
And that's, that's a hard
thing to, to go through.
It's a hard thing to
watch someone go through.
And she was talking about how hard it was,
like during the last season, like,
and just making it happen.
Like,... - [Linda] Yeah.
- what was that experience like for you?
- You know, I mean it's
just, you just hope you can,
you know, nobody wants to
see their, their friends,
or the people they love and
care about go about any...
You know, go through
anything that is difficult,
or challenging.
And I, we, we always laugh,
'cause it kind of looks
like a, maybe like a tampon
commercial,...
(distant audience amused laughing)
or something.
Like,...
- This is why I wanna call
her, and be friends with y'all.
Cause that is something I would say,
but I would find inappropriate.
But you said it, not me.
- [Linda] I can say that though;
that's just a feminine hygiene thing.
- But it would be
inappropriate if I said it,
'cause I'm not in the
photo. - [Linda] Yeah.
- But like it's amazing a..
- just super impose you in there
with like a box of tampons.
- [Kelly] Thank you, I'll be
the Olan Mills on the side.